your grace I feel I've been remiss in my
juices I've given you meat and wine
music but I haven't shown you the
hospitality you deserve my King has
married and I owe my new queen a wedding
gift
[Music]
this was an event that was not only from
the books but was one of the primary
reasons that we wanted to make this show
we thought that this was a getting to
the red wedding for us was such a major
milestone and such a source of
trepidation because yeah I remember how
it made me feel to read this thing there
to have this thing happen in a book I
was reading and not be able to believe
what I was what I was reading and there
was a tremendous responsibility there do
justice to it I remember the experience
in reading the book was kind of shocked
and and horror but then later how did I
not see that coming because you know all
the clues are there and certainly you
knew that rob was heading into a
dangerous situation but somehow your
guard drops and you realized that Ed
Murr despite all his fears he's not
marrying some hideous Frey monster he's
actually marrying this beautiful young
woman and that turned out really well
and it looks like hey this might have a
happy ending and of course it all starts
to change when you hear the rains of
castamere playing and do you think
that's not right so many of the stories
in this world revolve around the cost of
honor and the cost of love and all the
things that we consider to be good
things in our lives like love honor and
family loyalty and Duty and all of these
things end up losing people their heads
are getting them you know murdered at
their own wedding so what we were hoping
for with the scene is something similar
where things seem to be going so well
and then it all takes a very dark turn
and as you say it's not doesn't end
quickly it's not all over in a hail of
crossbow quarrels it's actually lingers
what we hope is for an uncomfortably
long
I mean that last shot of a cattle and
standing there I almost wanted to just
you kind of hoping for a cut to black
you just want it to be over because it's
you're watching this woman that you care
about so much in her absolute the most
horrible possible place a mother having
seen her own son killed before her eyes
and having really nothing left to live
for at that moment you know believing
all her other sons are dead and and
presumably her daughters are are dead or
at least in the grips of the Lannisters
and it's just all her husband has
preceded her alone before and that some
it's all over for her
[Music]
don't wallow enough let it end please
here's my son my first son Michelle and
in that last scene is just so powerful
you know her voice when she's when she's
talking to Walder Frey and I'm pleading
with them and you know you can hear me
talking about it's hard it's hard for me
in talk because it was just it was you
know and it's it's they're working in
this business for a while and certainly
you know working a lot of different you
know whether it's this show so many
different episodes or other movies but
there's never been a moment like that
for us
and we knew going into season one the
second shown being showed up on set for
the first day it was like hello we will
be chopping her head off three months
from now and everybody knew that and
that was was one of the ground rules we
knew obviously when Richard and Michelle
showed up for work on their first day we
distantly knew that somewhere in the
future these if we all got lucky enough
and the show didn't sink to the bottom
of the ocean in the middle of the first
season that it was in the back of our
minds that the red wedding was there
looming but it wasn't something that
really informed our daily lives working
with them so these people become like
family members to you and they're people
you spend so much time with and you fly
all over the place with and you you see
on screen off screen on set off set you
become very very close to Richard Madden
was so good at portraying rob that we
just kept writing more for him so you
know where rob is not a POV character in
the book so even though he's a very
important character he doesn't have a
huge amount of page time and we wonder
after we saw what he did in season one
we wanted him to have a great deal of
screen time so we kept writing more
scenes for him and several scenes that
either aren't in the book or are kind of
mentioned in the book but you don't
actually witness that we wanted to be
there for and so Richard became an
incredibly important part of the show
michelle has always been an incredibly
important part of the show and
the two of them are such a commanding
figures now they're so they're so
powerful in their presence and they're
so fun to write for and you know they're
really kind of the nobility of the show
the stark family has always been the
emotional core and they're getting
picked off one by one
you know or in this case two by two it's
like your favorite one of your favorite
cousins moving to Australia you're not
going to see them as often as you've
been seeing them in the past and they're
fixtures in your life and then all of a
sudden they're not fixtures in your life
anymore Munna as well somebody we we all
spent so much time with so it was a
definite personal aspect to it I think
for us most of the crew has been
together since the pilot and most the
cast you know so we're going back now to
five years and and you know so and I
remember being in the room with Richard
Madden first came in to audition for us
and remember the first time I saw
Michelle Fairley on stage and Othello
you know years ago and thought who is
that woman so the set for those days was
was especially the last day it was just
a very strange there's a very strange
atmosphere you know the people in
Northern Ireland are tough you know the
guys and our crew the guys that the men
and women I'm saying guys in the
gender-neutral way but like it's a tough
group like the Northern Irish or not or
not what season and and I've never seen
so many tears at this point I feel like
the world of the shows definitely
announced itself as a world where like
in our world were these horrible things
do happen to good people and the heroes
that you want to see come out on top and
triumph don't always come out on top and
triumph and I think that it it's very
much of a peace with with the fabric of
the show this is more about the cost of
love than the cost of Honor I remember
high school teacher wants to talking to
me about tragedy being not good versus
evil but good versus good and and what
you do when you're faced with two
conflicting goods and the good of
they love against the good of Honor and
keeping you're keeping your word and Rob
made a choice there and he it's taken a
while but he ends up paying for that
choice in the worst possible way in the
scene you go watch a spider-man movie
and there might be thrilling fights and
death-defying acts but you know
spider-man's gonna be there at the end
you know there's not that much dispense
and even in the fantasies that I've
loved before I mean Lord the Rings is
you know they're gonna defeat you know
the Dark Lord Sauron is not gonna win
and the hobbits aren't gonna get
massacred there's never been a good
versus evil epic fantasy that ended with
evil win it I'd like to see that movie
and maybe we will hear but you know it's
much more about the human journeys and
just as in real life sometimes the best
of us don't make it to the end don't
make it into an old age so it's it's
it's a difficult as a challenge always
in this show and it but it's also what
we love about it you know just that
sense that everyone is that risk even
the most beloved characters might not
make it to the next episode and that's
what we loved about the books and that's
what we're trying to recreate with the
series whether the Lannisters send their
regards
[Music]